We are sometimes swept away by a mood of sadness
that seems to have no cause. We wake up dispirited
and listless. We lack energy and direction.
Everything loses its taste and the smallest
challenges feel unfeasibly heavy. We struggle
to see the point of almost anything. We are
– as the doctors tell us – in a state
of severe depression. One of the strangest
but most provocative insights about depression
is found in works of psychoanalysis that tell
us that depression may not at heart be about
sadness; it is a kind of anger that has been
unable to find expression, that has turned
in on itself, and made us sad about everything
and everyone when we are in truth – deep
down – angry only about certain specific
things and specific people. If only we could
understand our disappointment and rage more
intimately, we could – the theory holds
– eventually regain our spirits. It isn’t
existence per se that has let us down, it
is a few particular events and actors whose
precise identity we have lost sight of. The
theory at once begs questions. How is it possible
that we be both profoundly angry and yet unaware
of the causes or direction of our annoyance?
However, this lack of self-knowledge is, in
terms of our overall mental functioning, not
entirely surprising or anomalous. We are endemically
bad at keeping close tabs on the origin and
nature of many of our feelings. We can laugh
deeply and yet struggle to explain exactly
why something has set us off. We can find
a landscape beautiful, a person charming or
a film nostalgia-inducing without having any
secure hold on the detailed mechanics of our
responses. Understanding has an established
habit of trailing far behind feeling. It isn’t
just around sadness and despair that we’re
strangers to ourselves. But there is another,
more pointed reason why we can lose touch
with our anger: because we have been taught,
probably since earliest childhood, that it
isn’t very nice to be angry. Anger violates
our image of ourselves as kindly and sympathetic
people. It can be too painful and guilt-inducing
to acknowledge that we may feel furious and
vengeful, not least towards people whom we
otherwise still love and who might have made
many sacrifices on our behalves. What we are
angry about may also sound absurd. Perhaps
we have been hurt by the sort of thing that
can be unhelpfully dismissed as ‘small’
and which we learn not to pay attention to
because we imagine ourselves as strong and
above being slighted by petty injuries; injuries
which wound us substantially just the same.
Lastly, we might be bad at getting angry because
we haven’t seen examples of successful expressions
of anger around us. We might associate the
word with volcanic crazed destruction, as
dangerous as it is counter-productive. Or
else we might have lived for too long surrounded
by people who never dared to raise their voices
and bitterly swallowed every hurt instead.
We have not learnt the art of a controlled
and cathartic conversation. The way out of
this sort of depression is to realise that
its alternative isn’t cheerfulness, but
mourning. Mourning is a useful word for it
indicates a focused kind of grief over an
identifiable kind of loss. As ‘mourners’,
we turn boundless, unnameable sadness into
much more specific hurt: a hurt about the
parent who wasn’t there for us, about the
sibling who mocked us, the lover who betrayed
us, the friend who lied. It isn’t necessarily
an idea to go out and confront these people
(some of them may already be dead anyway);
but mulling over what has happened and becoming
conscious of the full scale of our disavowed
rage and burden can decisively change our
mood all the same. Even as specific relationships
and episodes become more complicated in our
minds, life as a whole starts to appear more
manageable and hopeful. We’re never quite
done with the business of knowing our own
minds.